okay quick video on an exercise to get
used to momentarily taking weight off of
your foot without moving your body away
from it you will probably look silly
doing this but it will probably help
benefit your whirling exercises
go ahead and pick which foot that you'll
practice and shift your weight all the
way onto that foot
notice how your torso and upper body are
aligned over the foot test to make sure
that you're well balanced there by
lifting your other foot momentarily
now think about lifting the foot you've
got the weight on up into the air and
see what happens chances are you
probably shift your weight all the way
over to the other foot in order to lift
that foot up
however with practice you can keep your
torso centered over that same foot while
very quickly taking weight off of it
you